COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH IS HEREBY COLD
WAR. PLEASE BE ADVISED SEVEN
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED AMOUNT OF
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
FLORA. GRAYSON KAMLAGER. NINE
THERE MATH PRESENT HERSELF UP
HERE RAMOS. READ WICKS HERE
CARILLO HERE SO WE HAVE. WE
HAVE A WE HAVE GUESTS ENGINE IS
THERE A MOTION THAT SECOND OVER
MATH SECOND MISTER MOST OF
MATTER SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI COOLEY ARE CUTTING
CARILLO I CARILLO I'VE- FLORA I
AGREE SIR INTEGRATION I
KAMLAGER I CAN I MAY.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. MATH I
SILVA HI WORKS AYE ROOM. FROM
HOMES I READ. RIVAS AYE WORKS
FINE SIDE PASSED MOTIONS AND I
THINK TO WALL FOR BEING WITH US.
SO THIS FEDERAL TWENTY CENTER.
THAT SAID YEAH.